- On this episode we talk IP law.
(laughing)
What I'd do with a thousand dollars,
and a shit load of homies
decided to join us!
Show them, DRock, show them, show them.
And over here, show them, for the intro,
yeah the intro, and over there, hi.
(cheering and clapping)
(bass-heavy music)
You ask questions, and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
(bass-heavy music)
Hey everybody, this is
Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 97
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Beautiful day, New York City.
I was dominant in basketball this morning,
I just want to start with that.
I really had a really good day.
you know what sucks, DRock
is that, we were filming
but we had a stationary
filming, so I'm not sure
what we caught, but when
you make that many baskets,
I'm sure that some of them would show up.
Real excited, 97, getting
very close to episode 100.
Steve came in, this is a lot
of people in the room actually.
Mike! Mike is here!
I mean, this is a, Andrew's rarely here.
Ya know, yep, I mean this
is, Zak hasn't been here
in a long time.
- I still work here.
(laughs)
- This is a good show, I'm excited.
Steve came in to just, ya know,
tell me a bunch of things
about Monday's episode 100.
And then I said, ya know
what, just stay and tell them,
but I'm remembering things.
P two, pool bar, at the Gansevoort.
- [Steve] That's right.
- Four P.M.
Opening the doors, four
thirty sharp starting time.
Another one that we don't wanna tell them,
it is a 21 and older venue,
which means a lot of people's
hearts, a collective
hearts were just broken.
I feel like there's some
college kids getting
some road trips that I really screwed up,
but here's my curve ball.
As I told you, I've gotta
be in and out there.
But, I am going to a
Mets game with a friend
and business associate,
so I have to go do that.
But baseball's boring enough
that I can see myself leaving
in the fourth, fifth, or sixth inning,
and coming back in the city,
using my Twitter account,
maybe we'll create a hashtag, ya know,
and meet a bunch of people somewhere.
I'm 80% into that, who
knows, I could get tired,
which happens once in a blue moon,
maybe I just wanna go home, so
I don't wanna give promises,
but I love the idea of you
guys all being together.
And of course, I wanna be there if I can,
especially 'cause so many
of you are schlepping.
So I'm super excited.
This venue holds about
200, the RSVP thing's
all screwed up 'cause it's
861, but it's not really that,
so I think we should be fine.
So we'll keep it at that,
the first people in,
I guess, at some level then.
If you're coming from a far away place,
leave a comment or, and
Facebook or YouTube.
I kinda feel like, I'm gonna say this.
If you are coming from
more than 90 minutes away,
I'm gonna make sure you get in.
I feel like we'll be okay,
doesn't seem like it's gonna be
that many people doing
that, so there's that.
That's all the house cleaning
that I can think of for that.
India, let's get into the show.
(light bass-heavy music)
- [Nicole] Evan asks,
"Do you distinguish between
'idea people' and 'doers'?
"Is there value in someone
with great ideas
"who needs others to execute?"
- Ya know, I think that,
one of the things that I've
pounded home in a hundred episodes here is
how much pride I have
in being a practitioner.
How much I am, how much
I respect practicality.
Like, how much ideas are shit,
and execution's the game, that's
one of my favorite quotes.
Right? So, but it's interesting.
This question, as it rolled
off of India's tongue,
made me realize, ya know,
truth is there is value in it.
Ya know what? Here's a good way to put it.
One of the reasons I think
I pound ideas are shit
and execution's the
game, is because I think
the majority of people that
spend a lot of time watching me,
aren't at a place where they can afford
the luxury of ideas.
Silent pause for profoundness.
Let me explain.
Ideas are great.
Ideas are, ya know, you can really overt,
I like being a contradiction
of ideas are the game, right?
Ideas are a seed.
But so many people don't have the luxury
of being able to afford the
ability to have those ideas.
For a long time, I
didn't have the luxury of
building a company that
had great video people
who could come with me and
tape my garage sale show,
and now I do and I can't
wait, I'm so pumped.
We have to find a town sale,
that's where all the action is.
Anyway,
so, I think there is a
place for idea people,
India and VaynerNation, I think it is a,
it's a (chuckles), Ranger
people are excited.
I think that you have to have
the luxury of those people.
I think, the reason I'm
hedging here is I'm scared
so many of you are like, "See?
"He said idea people,
and I'm an idea person."
Ya know, ya can't be, you've
gotta be in the right setting
to get the right value of
ideas, which is a huge company
that could afford R&D,
research and development,
ya know, that kinda thing.
You just got really
lucky that your partner
is so Goddamn practical that
he or she respects your
idea skills and wants them.
But it is a really rare situation
for ideas to be valuable
in its execution form,
especially for the far majority
of the VaynerNation.
(light bass-heavy music)
- [Nicole] Albi asks,
"You say you don't consume much media
"but isn't it kind of necessary in order
"to put out relevant, current content?"
- Albi, that is a tremend, man!
I'm feelin' really good about
this show, some new kind of
topic stuff, like India's
hacking, India needs new articles,
so she's forcing me in
a different direction,
so I'm impressed India, I
see what you're doing here.
- [India] They're all planned.
- Albi, that's a great question.
The reason I think I produce
such relevant, good content,
is because I'm listening
to my community and that is
my consumption of media.
So, I don't listen to
other thought leaders,
I don't watch other shows, I don't,
this is my relaxation, right?
Like I don't need things to unwind,
I'm always unwinding, even
though it doesn't seem so.
And so, to me, I think
the reason I'm able to
produce good content, is I'm listening.
Look at the content of this show.
Ya know, don't have to do
much, just gotta answer your
Goddamn question, right?
Giving people value by listening.
It's funny, I said
something the other day,
that really makes sense.
If you ever get a chance
to jam with me, or
this is something interesting
for you guys to hear.
When you know what somebody's ask,
so I cut people off constantly, right?
As you guys all can
attest to, because if I,
and I have good intuition
very often, like very often,
I already know what you're about to say,
and I'd much rather us move on
to the next part of execution
that giving you the extra
13 seconds to finish
your fucking sentence.
So, people don't think I
listen, but all I do is listen,
and so I think the reason
I produce good content
is I'm watching, do you know
how many of you I'm watching
of what you're tweeting
about, when it doesn't
have to do with me?
When you're putting out at other places?
Why do you think I get
so pissed at all of you?
Right, because you all say, "Yeah Gary,
"he's right about this," and
none of you are doing it!
Do you know few of you
were actually listening?
Do you know how many of
you that have watched
all 97 of these episodes still
still aren't putting in that work,
aren't executing properly
on that platform,
aren't playing the long game,
are cutting shortcuts,
aren't putting in the time,
having tested dark posts,
not playing enough.
Like, do you know how many? Too many.
(bass-heavy music)
- [Nicole] Benjamin asks,
"I mustache you a question.
"What's your opinion on brands
"building social campaigns around
"consumers taking selfies?
#mugmustache"
- Ya know, this is kind of
a, I loved your picture,
so I don't wanna dis you.
This is an interesting question.
Meaning, it's very easy answer.
What do I think, I think, of course.
Selfie culture is real, it's important.
I think it's a noisy space.
I often, when I go do brainstorms,
think selfies right away
because it's so in culture.
I think it's not a white space.
I think that, too many
brands are doing things
with selfies, too many
people are doing things
with selfies, too startups.
I already think it's kind of
like, I don't wanna call it
jump the shark, but
like, ya know, it's fine.
By the way, the ironic thing
about making this statement,
if you ask me what's one of
the most likely categories
of the breakout marketing
hit in the next year,
I would say selfies, even with
the answer I just told you.
Meaning for me,
the reason I was tough
on the question is like,
that was literally asking me
like, what do you think about
oxygen, like do you think
it's important? Yes.
What do I think? Of course, yes.
It's a mundane answer, it's like yeah.
I think it's cool, I think it's not cool.
Meaning, they're doing it,
somebody could even have
a breakout hit if they come up with some
clever version of theirs.
I don't think it's that interesting.
I think it's been going
on for 24 to 36 months.
(bass-heavy music)
- [Nicole] Amanda asks,
"I just watched episode 96 &
you went off on IP.
"I'm an IP lawyer starting out.
"What is the future
and where does IP fit?"
- Uh, (laughs).
- [India] Sorry!
- That's a great question.
(sighs) Listen, IP is real, by the way,
I believe in pendulums, pendulums, right?
So, I'm very down in IP.
I think entrepreneurs
should not be spending
that much time on it.
But, I actually think
12, 15, 20, 30 years,
40 years from now, as I
think more entrepreneurs
of this generation don't think about it,
that it will become a white space.
And there'll be an opportunity
to make a lot of money in it
because it's still law, right?
Ya know what, I think IP and patents
fall into the category of
building the biggest building in town
by tearing everybody else's building.
I met this guy, he was
so proud of himself.
He's like, "I fucking
got all these patents,
"and one day somebody's gonna do something
"and I'm gonna get him."
I'm like, "Fuck you!"
And he was like, so taken
aback because we were
introduced by good friends.
I was so pissed.
I hate that.
Now, IP, like ya know,
I think it's important.
If you draw Mickey Mouse,
you don't want other people,
like I get it.
I think there's a place for it.
But also, the supply and
demand of amazing creative
or ideas or whatever else
can be categorized in IP,
is in a very different place
too, because everything can see
the day of light now, right?
You don't have to work
at a Disney or a Fox,
or a media company, or like
be an amazing scientist
and working at GE.
Kickstarter has created
every, it's just that we're
living in this incredible,
it's not the place
that even intuitively
feels like the right place
to play in right now,
because the supply and demand
alternatives of the
marketplace dictate a behavior
to me that's all the different.
Now, with that being said,
back to being an IP lawyer,
I think what you should figure out,
where all your upside professionally is
can you become a taste
maker, a forward thinker?
Can you figure out, and I
know I'm asking you now,
can you figure out a
version of becoming the
IP lawyer 2.0, like
what's the future of IP?
Question of the day!
Uh,
Andrew asks it!
(laughs)
- Who you got tonight,
Rangers or the Capitals?
- Yeah, that's what he's got.
Which means nothing to 99.9%
of you, great job Andrew.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Hell yeah, that'd be super (bleeps) cool.
I'm super pumped right now.
Me and AJ made a show,
we called it Trash Talk.
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] Nice.
- And I'd come back
and be like I just, it was so funny.
I'd be like, "I just bought
this Michael Jordan jersey
"for two dollars, and
I hate Michael Jordan,
"but I'm gonna do it 'cause it
can sell for 40 on the Bay."
I always called eBay the Bay.
(laughing)
All right, India.
- [India] Have you wrote--
- You're not editing, right?
You're still in black-and-white mode,
I told that to somebody
today in the TV world,
they thought it was brilliant, by the way.
I'm curious, as a matter of
fact, little comment section.
Can you guys give me
feedback on how you like
the whole black-and-white
to color transition?
(mumbles)
(rattling)
- [India] Oh my gosh.
- You caught my reaction to that, right?
Another scared moment.
(laughing)
- [Staphon] There were two
cameras, we both got it.
(laughing)
Did you get it?
Ah! All right.
- [India] Have you
heard about the Facebook
Instant Articles thing?
- I have heard about it.
Obviously, it's completely
taken over like our world.
Unfortunately I haven't
played with it yet.
- [India] Do you wanna answer a question?
- Not until I play with it,
so we'll answer it next week.
See, this is the cool part
of black-and-white, right?
- [India] Yeah.
- 'Cause that was like an
answer to an answer, DRock.
(bass heavy music)
(bell dinging)
♫ Jab
♫ Right hook
♫ Right hook ♫